سعودي في كييف تاكيد على قدره الرياض على
الحفاظ على علاقاتها مع طرفي الحرب علاقه
مساعده لاوكرانيا وعمل سياسي ودبلوماسي مع
روسيا خلال الزياره التقى وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان بالرئيس
الاوكراني
نتج عنها اتمام حزمه المساعدات التي تعهد
بها ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان للرئيس الاوكراني قبل اشهر قليله
وتشمل الحزمه مساعدات انسانيه اضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل الى 400 مليون دولار
منها 100 مليون دولار لتنفيذ برنامج سعودي
اوكراني مشترك بين مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه ووزاره تنميه
المجتمعات والاقاليم في اوكرانيا فيما
تضمنت الاتفاقيه تقديم مليون دولار على
شكل منحه مشتقات نفطيه جرى توقيعها بين
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه ووزاره الطاقه
الاوكرانيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان جدد خلال الزياره
دعم السعوديه لجميع الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
سياسيا ومواصله جهودها للاسهام في تخفيف
الاثار الانسانيه الناجمه عنها المملكه
حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب دور سعودي لما يقتصر على الجانب
السياسي او حتى الانساني في الداخل
الاوكراني بل شمل ايضا المقيمين
الاوكرانيين على الاراضي السعوديه عبر
منحهم تسهيلات خاصه لحين انتهاء الازمه في
بلادهم جهود وساطه مست مره تبذلها الرياض
في ازمه اوكرانيا بدات بالافراج عن عشره
اسرى من 50 جنسيات ولن تنتهي بزياره الامس
التاريخيه الى
رئيس مركز الخليج الابحا الدكتور عبد
العزيز حياك الله دكتور اولا بالنظر الى
توقيت الزياره وظروف الحرب اليوم
والتصريحات حول عدم قبول اي طرف باي نهج
سلمى
وطبيعه وحجم المساعدات التي قدمتها
السعوديه لاوكرانيا هل تغير السعوديه
موقفها من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اولا مساء الخير استاذ خالد المشاهدين
العربيه في كل مكان في الحقيقه هذا
استمرار لموقف المملكه من البدايه وهو
انها ترفض الاحتلال بقوه او استخدام العنف
هي تؤكد على وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه هي
لا تقبل او ما يسمى باستخدام القوه
العسكريه الاحتلال يعني اي جزء من هذا هي
تتفهم الدوافع الروسيه فيما يتعلق بانها
القومي المهم في هذه الجانب هي ايضا
قامت بدور وساطه في يعني مثل ما ذكر
تقريركم بالنسبه لبعض السجناء اللي كانوا
موجودين الاسرى في ذلك الوقت وكان هذا جاد
بطلب من الحكومه البريطانيه على فكره في
الاساس والمملكه استجابت واستطاعت بفضل
سمو دور ولي العهد في هذا الجانب باطلاق
سراح هؤلاء الاسرى هذه المواقف كلها كانت
تعتبر ضمن الموقف المحايد لانها صوتت
الامم المتحده صوتت في مجلس التعاون دول
الخليج العربي ضد استخدام العنف وضد هذا
الموقف المتوازن ياتي كيف ياتي في قضيتين
مهمه ياتي في انه
ليس بالضروره نقطع علاقتي مع روسيا وليس
بالضروره ان اقف مع المعسكر المعادي
لروسيا في هذا الجانب انا لي مصالحي ولي
علاقاتي انا ناديت من اليوم الاول باللجوء
الى الحل الطرق السياسيه والدبلوماسيه لحل
هذه الازمه انا ضد استخدام العنف او
الوسيله وارى انه البعد الانساني مهم
ولذلك المساهمه الانسانيه اللي قدمتها
المملكه 400 مليون دولار موزعه 100 مليون
دولار بشكل مساعدات انسانيه
هي تاكيد على موقف المملكه للدعم الانساني
والسياسي في هذا الجانب فهو انت هو هو
بالتاكيد وقوف مع
الطرف المتضرر وهو وهي اوكرانيا في هذا
الجانب ولذلك يعني هذه الزياره مهمه طبعا
انا احيي شجاعه سمو الامير فيصل لانه راح
بالقطار وتعلنا هو ولفد المرافق معه سواء
معالي الدكتور الربيعه او المدير الصندوق
السعودي اللي ذهبوا معه هؤلاء جميعا ذهبوا
موقف خادم الحرمين الشريفين موقف سمو
للعهد والحكومه السعوديه في انها تراعي
الجوانب الانسانيه ترى اهميتها تقف يعني
في الازمات الموقف الذي يجب هل هذا يعني
انه هذا الموقف هذه الزيارات بالتنسيق مع
الطرف الروسي وكذلك مع الطرف الغربي دكتور
عبد العزيز ليس بالضروره انها جاءت
بالتنسيق او ليست بالضروره ان تحسب انها
يعني استجابه لمطالب غربيه وانما هي
استمرار للنهج السعودي من اول يوم على
فكره هنالك اساءه فهم الموقف السعودي الكل
اعتبر ان اسرار المملكه على موضوع اوبيك
بلس هو انحياز لجانب روسيا وهذا غير صحيح
اثبتت الدلائل بان المملكه بموقفها في
الاوبك بلس حافظت على اسعار النفط حافظت
على الاسواق والتوازنها ولم يكن موقفا
منحزن روسيا لما رات مصلحتها ان تبيع
باسعار منخفضه الى الهند والى الصين بناقص
اكثر من 30% من الاسعار العالميه خدمت
مصلحتها في هذا الجانب وباعت بهذا لكن
الغرب حينما راى انه يؤكد على يعني
تحجيم الدور الروسي اقتصاديا عسكريا
سياسيا اوقف الاستيراد من روسيا واخذ موقف
واضح في هذا وبدا يبحث عن بدائل حتى وان
كان كلفه الكثير والكثير منه دكتور لكن
الغرب له موقف اخر وخاصه الامريكيين يمكن
في ميونخ التي جئتها يعني امس تقريبا كان
لك سؤال طرحته على وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
في هذا الخصوص حول موقف دول الخليج من
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كان وزير
الخارجي واضحا في ردته
لا توازن في هذه الحرب او لا موقف متوازن
في هذه الحرب بما ان تكون معنا بمعنى من
تكون معنا او ضدنا فبالتالي الى اي مدى
يعني السعوديه وكذلك دول الخليج وغيرها من
الدول في المنطقه هي قادره على البقاء في
هذا الموقع موقع التوازن او عدم الانحياز
خاصه نحن نتحدث عن تصاعد في العمليات
العسكريه
وامداد غربي كبير بكل انواع الاسلحه
والتقارير تتحدث يعني عن
مرحله اخرى ستدخل فيها الحرب الربيع
المقبل يعني دكتور ما رايك فيها صحيح انا
يعني في السؤال الوزير الخارجي حاولت ان
اشرح الموقف الخليجي واساله انه شو موقفه
هو من هذا الموقف المتوازن مثل ما هم
قبلوه للهند وقبلوه لتركيا وقبلوه
لاسرائيل لماذا لا يقبل لدول الخليج هذا
الموقف وهو كان جوابه واضح انه
لا يوجد توازن حينما يوجد استخدام العنف
في هذا الجانب يكون في طرف متضرر اتفهم
الموقف الامريكي لان الموقف الامريكي قائم
هو والغربي قائم على فرضيه واحده انه لا
يمكن السماح بانتصار روسيا ولا يمكن
السماح عسكريا ولا يمكن السماح بتغيير
خارطه الجغرافيا السياسيه في تلك المنطقه
هذا الموقف الامريكي الواضح ولذلك هو لا
يريد اي مواقف متوازنه هو يريد هزيمه
كامله مع انه هذا احد السيناريوهات
المتوقعه في مستقبل متعدده هذا احداها وهو
الهزيمه الكامله لكذا السيناريو الاخر هو
ان يحقق الروس انتصار فيصير هناك تفاوض
يعني سواء باستخدام القوه العسكريه
المفرطه المباغته عمل يعني خارج عن الاطار
المتداول والمالوف فتحقق فايضا هذا
السيناريو اخر سيناريو ثلاث استمرار وضع
كما هو وقف اطلاق النار ولكن لا يوجد حل
سياسي وهذا ممكن ان يستمر فتره مثلا اطول
القرم شبه جزيره القرم لا احد يتحدث عنها
من الغربيين فربما يكون هنالك سيناريو اخر
تخفيض المساحه التي استولت عليها روسيا
يعني بدلا من ان تكون 20% من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه 10% او جزء منها يقبل حتى يكون
مخرج سياسي مقبول فيقبل الطرفين بهذه
المساومه السيناريوهات المتعدده كلها
انا في قناعتي ما زال مبكر انه نشوف نتائج
لانه امريكا قررت ان تزيد حجم الدعم
العسكري الى 50 مليون ربما يجعلنا نذهب
الى السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا عند الكثير
من الخبراء والمحللين وهو ان
يتحول هذا الصراع الى صراع طويل الامد بين
بين روسيا واوكرانيا والغرب لانه استنزافي
بشكل كبير يعني اليوم اليوم يعني قرروا
مبلغ بسيط في البدايه 140 مليار دولار
تقريبا في اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا من
اين سوف ياتي هذا المبلغ سوف ياتي من
المبالغ الروسيه التي تم الحجز عليها في
اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا فهنا ايضا يعني
هزيمه سياسيه من ناحيه هزيمه اقتصاديه لم
تقبل بهزيمتها في اوكرانيا ومستعده
لاستخدام كل انواع الاسلحه حتى سيناري اخر
ايضا لم نتطرق له وهو وقف اطلاق النار
والانسحاب وليس هزيمه
يعني هذا ايضا خيار روسي ممكن ان يكون
اليوم يوقف اطلاق النار ويسحب قواته فهذا
انسحاب وليس هزيمه هذه الدول قادره على
التعامل مع هذه السيناريوهات والبقاء في
ذات المنطقه اما ان الامر سيختلف
دول بلطيق امام مخاطره اسبانيا الدول هذه
ايضا هي امام يعني خطر روسي كبير الخوف
انه لو نجحت روسيا في في اوكرانيا ان
تتمدد وان تعود الى مناطق الى مولدوفيا
الى الى هذه المناطق وتحاول ان تعيد بسط
النفود لان الكل او الغربيين يتحدثون لا
امبراطوريه روسيه بدون اوكرانيا ومولدن
فهذه ايضا سيناريو اخر يطرح نفسه في هذا
الجانب لكن الموقف الواضح اليوم ان هنالك
التزام غربي اكيد
بدعم اوكرانيا بعدم السماح لروسيا بتحقيق
اي انتصار عسكري هنالك هزائم كبيره
الحقيقه في الجانبين من الناحيه البشريه
او من ناحيه العداد العسكري التجهيزات
الجديده التي منحت لاوكرانيا بما فيها
الدبابات الالمانيه هي جزء دفاع هي موجه
لمناطق تريد ان تزيل الاحتلال عنها
وتحررها فهذا ايضا يطرح نفسه بشكل اخر
شكرا